what's great about your story is that
you are indie filmmakers making a
product for fellow into filmmakers so
shouldn't we I mean don't you feel that
other any filmmakers should give you
sort of a break-in how long something
takes for us we made a film we thought
great it'll take a year to finish we
crowd funded on Kickstarter it took
three years and every day there was an
inertia that weight us down because it
wasn't done so do you think that people
realize sometimes how long things take
and shouldn't maybe I know even on this
scarlet website I saw something like you
know subject to you know we reserve the
right to cancel orders especially if you
know you're you're rude on the phone
there was just something about that so
do you think people realize that things
take time things don't go as planned and
they're setbacks yeah as far as the
delay just about everybody has actually
been really nice about it and we have
had very few people say anything
negative i as far as kickstarter yeah I
have I back more than 75 projects myself
and the technology projects are
generally late you know I backed a a
small sensor project that is going on
almost a year late they're just starting
to deliver now I back the the adult
tricycle project which is now over a
year and a half late and some other
things like that so I think people
understand and we try to make updates
once a week we're available on
on the forum every day practically how
we tweet regularly we're on Facebook and
we just recently about three weeks ago
started every monday at 11am pacific
standard time we're on ustream to answer
questions for anybody that wants to come
join us and so we're trying very hard to
communicate with our kickstarter backers
and other people who are interested in
the product and what people know where
we're at but yeah i think people
understand the other thing that's
interesting is because we started the
forum and we've been talking to people
and we've heard reviews of other cameras
from philip bloom and people like that
we've actually made over a hundred
changes to the camera since March so
there are now over a hundred different
things that are different some of them
small like a screw being moved over half
an inch or something like that but some
of them are really large like adding the
HDMI port or bumping the sound up to 24
96 kilohertz 24-bit 96 kilohertz or we
heard a need for a higher end video
output so we couldn't afford to put that
in there but what we did was we put in
an extra data path that went to the
bottom of the camera so that in the
future we can have something like an HD
SDI module to the bottom of the can
this was not planned at march during the
watch so all these things that have been
added of course we take time so we hope
that the ultimate product that the
Kickstarter backers get is going to be
quite a bit better than the one that
they pledged on and yes it took a little
more time to get to them but will be
quite a bit better of a product with not
a dollar extra expense on their part
yeah I mean I think something that you
know everything always takes longer than
you expect it to take especially with a
creative project inspection is efficient
a collaborative project where there's so
many different factors involved you know
they're there stops and sorts even
donate this baby but if you have the
full budget and I think especially
through projects funded on Kickstarter
the filmmakers themselves have anyone
who has started a project on Kickstarter
they feel an overwhelming accountability
and sometimes what they do is instead of
sharing which is not like the first
thought that you would have is like to
share all the problems that you're going
a lot of them feel like they can't
update and they shouldn't share those
things and that's what's good sometimes
create problems between the backers and
the creatives that have started the
campaign is that you know when people
are donating to a Kickstarter they
understand that these are people that
you know can't get the money from
somewhere else they're generally
starting out especially on the
technology products and most of them are
people that haven't developed that kind
of product before and people are
donating to the dream they are donating
to help these people you know out there
may be other motivations to such as you
know they want to see the process
because maybe they want to create
something similar and they want to see
how it goes for somebody else first
there's many reasons but most of them
are emotional most people don't
necessarily kick start a project because
they want the item many people are
donating because they want to
legitimately help the people out or
they're interested in the product once
it reaches viability and so I think that
while people don't want to disappoint
their backers the correct thing to do is
to actually share the story and share
what you're changing
and what the hiccups are and I think
that while one might think that would
cause a negative impression I think
that's one of the reasons why we have
had such a positive reaction is that we
update constantly and as joe said we've
like very strong communication between
us and our backers and we make ourselves
available you know every single day to
them and that has also created a really
great community around the camera and
with the forum are you both muttering
yeah Joe's on it much more than I
I kind of tend to go to the Twitter
Facebook side and he goes to the forum
side but you know we there's a lot of
this type of social media that you know
we both answer emails we both moderate
comments on the website we both write
blog posts and it'll shift you know who
is focusing more and some things and he
was focusing more on other things but
that's something that we feel that we
need to do personally because you know
we want people
people believe in us and we want them to
continue to believe in us so we don't
want to cut ourselves off or create a
kind of middle person in there our
forums are
sort of uniquely populated by crazy
hyper intelligent people that are really
really technical and I myself who have a
lot of
background and technical stuff and have
been reading about it for many years
often have to go research for half an
hour to answer someone's forum post
because they're really really smart yeah
there's a lot of crazy crazy smart
people on our forum that the offer
really good ideas that's why the camera
has changed so much since March this
because they have given us amazing
amazing ideas that really are are above
and beyond what we expected and we're
very thankful to have such a smart
community to have to help us
you